President Trump in first Lady Melania
met with doctors first responders and
survivors of Sunday's massacre roll the
tape the patience the bravery some were
very very badly wounded and they were
badly wounded because they refused to
leave they wanted to help others because
there's so people going down all over
and it's an incredible thing to see this
tremendous bravery the police department
incredible the people themselves
incredible people leaving ambulances to
have somebody else go because they
thought they were hurt even more so
meanwhile here's new body cam footage
taken from police officers from that
night remember when body cams were used
to capture police infractions but here
the reveal men running into a hail of
bullets pure heroism that vastly dwarves
the abuses that the media magnifies and
players kneel over so from heroes to
zeroes see this cartoon from the Vermont
paper it's a pile of bodies with the
caption what happens in Vegas etc by
Randall eNOS
it reveals how detached leftists are
from humanity the paper the Bennington
banner apologized they claimed they were
just trying to spur a debate well
there's no debate your paper sucks
speaking of pathetic attention seekers
at Drexel University professor Blaine's
trumpism through Vegas tweeting white
people and men are told that they are
entitled to everything this is what
happens when they don't get what they
want
that's a Drexel professor the same ghoul
who once called for white Janis
you know it seems like there are more
racist creeps in academia than the
general population I ask parents why
send your kids to Drexel I think that
might be child abuse back to the heroes
how about that marine vet who stole a
truck to help transport victims from the
killing field to the hospital lucked out
on the first track open the door and the
keys were there and looked at Jen said
let's go get some people each trip was
10 to 15 people as many as we could cram
in there we were just trying to go down
the line of the dozens and dozens of
people that were already being pulled
out to the street it was really hard to
just pack up and leave because you know
you can only fit so many people and
there's so many people that still needed
help and no ambulances were on scene yet
so there's a comparison a military hero
and a professor zero one inspires the
other repulses I'm thinking the military
offers the far better education than
academia at least in moments that matter
in life I ask myself what I have learned
more in a barracks instead of going to
Berkley yes the answer is yes you read
my mind Kimberly I think because my
education I think of myself as a last
responder I'm the one that's running all
right Dana what did you think of the
president's remarks today well you never
want to necessarily get better at
disaster recovery because that means
that you're actually having to go to a
lot of disasters but this is a
presidency that's only nine months into
it's four years possibly eight and he I
don't know if it's growing into it but
the remarks are always spot-on so
there's two things I've noticed one is
that when he is one-on-one with people
and it's not scripted he's really good
he always has been mm-hmm and in some
ways at his rallies remember and he's
not on a teleprompter it's almost as if
he's talking to each person individual
and he likes the crowd but what he did
in Puerto Rico yesterday
was to let the people know like I came
so I took the time to come I promise you
that we're going to be here to help and
I touched a few people individually so
that means a lot then you go to if you
look at Monday when he did the speech
with a diplomatic reception room
immediately after the tragedy that was
beautiful presidential oratory and then
too
day you have them at the University
Medical Center and he's always with the
first lady Melania Trump by his side and
I could think about what it means to the
people that are in the hospital
recovering from these horrible wounds
that the president took the time to come
he spent an hour longer than was he was
meant to with when he was there and then
he's talking to the medical responders
and what this does for him as well is it
gets him out of the Oval Office it's one
of the things I kept thinking at this
first eight months before there was a
changeover in leadership at the White
House is why do tonight they not get him
out of Washington Washington is not
where he should be that he is not a
creature of Washington of course he has
to sort of manage the White House but
once they've been getting him out into
the country was giving speeches in
Indiana and Missouri on tax reform
traveling around to do other things see
people he does a lot better and I think
he represents all of us well because we
can't go there to the hospital but we
can all feel pretty inspired by what he
said today hmm let me throw to another
piece of tape from President Trump and
then I'll ask Kimberly your thoughts the
example of those whose final act was to
sacrifice themselves for those they
loved should inspire all of us to show
more love every day for the people who
grace our lives in the months ahead we
will all have to wrestle with the horror
of what has unfolded this week but we
will struggle through it together we
will endure the pain together and we
will overcome together as Americans
thoughts Kimberly you know I really
think it was a powerful moment for the
president and you can feel that he's
speaking from his heart that it's
genuine and I think when you go there
there's really no substitute to actually
going to the scene going to the place
whether it's a natural disaster or a
horrific and mass shooting like happened
in Las Vegas you know you really feel it
and I think it's it's important for the
country to see that I'm glad that he
went there and for anyone to question
why he went there they would criticize
him if he didn't and absolutely the
president belongs there this was so
tragic and the fact that it was the
largest mass shooting in American you
know history in and of itself is so
significant and it deserves the
president
and the contemplation and reflection of
the president Jessie these events always
reveal two sides more there's usually
more heroes than zeroes but the zeroes
are kind of more interesting because
they're just so bad but yeah I mean when
tragedy strikes people can decide if
they want to be heroes or villains the
heroes run towards the bullets they
donate blood they donate money they they
console a victim they explain to
children what exactly happened but the
villains seek to divide instead of unite
they exploit this for personal gain for
financial gain they write silly cartoons
and it's it's a mess now
social media and TV has a way of holding
a mirror up to this country and that's
good because it shows who the real
haters are we have a professor like this
that blames all white men or the
shooting when there's a terrorist attack
does he blame all Muslims of course not
or Hillary Clinton who demonized the
Second Amendment right on the heels of
this struck the wrong note the CBS
executives said she has no sympathy for
any of these victims even CNN said the
only reason he rushed to Vegas was
because he had a hotel there it's really
disgusting and then the press can't
belong of the country and then turn
around at the same time and contribute
to that same polarization if you're
gonna blame Trump for charlottesville or
mock milania's heels for Harvey or lie
about the Puerto Rico recovery or even
say that every member of Congress is
complicit in the shooting death of 59
people you can't do that so the media
spent I think what three or four or five
years denigrating law enforcement some
of those stories were fake news but
other those stories you know there's
some bad apples there and I have to
admit that but at the same time now as
an opportunity for the media to tell
those heroic stories and sing the
praises of law enforcement and not just
the police but the EMTs the SWAT teams
because they saved a lot of lives out
there and the media has so many
resources they can bring to bear towards
a tragedy especially the networks and
you see there's an appetite out there
especially after what we saw in Texas to
hear stories of personal bravery and
instead of spotlighting those great
stories that are the real
America they're focused on the
bitterness and the divisive nasaw of the
country and that's what you see but
that's not the real America Richard if I
remember what your mother a nurse she is
yes so I'm sure when you look at this
stuff you know when you look at the
first responders in the hospital and and
what's happening right now it must mean
something to you oh it absolutely does
and I always like to take these moments
to shut out those individuals right so I
mean I think we saw the president today
with the police with the police and with
the EMTs but a lot of some of these
health care professionals are still
working and they're still dealing with
the four hundred and five hundred
victims that are still in the hospital
today so a big shout out to all the
health care professionals that are still
working at the University Medical Center
Sunrise Hospital Medical Center st. Rosa
dominicana Hospital they have three
campuses all in Las Vegas who are
dealing with the many many many victims
some of these nurses are working three
four or five shifts to deal with the
volume of patients so a big shout out to
them they are true American heroes in my
book they probably aren't sleeping no
not at all story about they I think is
that the University Medical Center a
friend of mine has a friend who just got
his residency last week and started
there and that his first on duty Monday
this is this is what happened or Sunday
night he works the weekend wow what a
way to break in and I don't think nobody
really knows the toll that it takes on
these individuals so my mom was she was
also part of the irma team in Miami and
they she literally slept on the hospital
floor for three days when the hospital
ran out of power they were still there
um taking care of patients so they
really do yeoman's work they're also
doing the same type of work in Puerto
Rico so big shout out to all the health
care professionals you know what I go
back to this this the bennington banner
it's a small paper out of southern
Vermont they've apologized what I find
interesting about their apology is that
they regret it they said they were
trying to spur a debate because they
felt that you know nothing ever gets
done after this so like I could say I
could see if somebody said oh we were
just making a sick joke like okay but
when you tie when you justify a sick
joke by saying well we're politically
superior right we're coming from a
superior politically superior point of
view therefore we felt this was
appropriate we realized were wrong
because of the outcry find that
can I ask you if you were in publishing
what would you would you have apologized
that never would have rubber and never
letter by ever would have run it was a
cartoon to get out I have a sick sense
of humor you know I
but I even like I look at that I go I
will a it's a terrible cartoon I would
have thought if I was if I owned that
paper I would have fired the editor
it's a terrible paper we had some
run-ins with the bennington baron or
when I worked on The O'Reilly Factor I'm
sure they are tremendously dishonest
they would side against rape victims
child rape victims when we did a lot of
the Jessica's law coverage up there they
were giving really soft sentence to
child rapist and we went up and
confronted some of the editors up there
and there are total cowards would not
justify any of the editorials up there
it's a very fringe far-left paper
they're extremely responsible so it
doesn't surprise me at all that they
would run such an offensive cartoon and
I don't even buy the justification I
don't buy that at all they thought it
was cute and edgy and they ran it then
got called out so they apologized the
drugs sold think too it's interesting
cuz this guy I didn't mention his name
on purpose but he has a history of doing
these kind of inflammatory things I'm
assuming he has tenure yeah cuz the CBS
lawyer got fired right I could do mean
you probably got up that's that's the
ideal of academia you come to academia
you get tenure knew your job is to sort
of do research and to say thing my
reason why I say it is because you know
what some people took thirty years ago
when people were like you know gay the
gay people should get married
everybody was like this is blasphemy
this is the worst thing in the world
these pictures should be shunned and now
look at it we're in 2017 the reason why
there's university tenure is to protect
these a cadiz academics who say things
and also I think that you know times
change I don't think the his bosses at
the college are going like no that's for
Twitter it's like yeah I think he's I
think he's basically thinks he can do
this and an excuse to get away with
their poor judgment and
morally depraved and disgusting so
there's no excuse for him there you go
let the payment visit when Kimberly says
there's no excuse for you oh you've got
a pretty bad